jubilation and relief it seems they've
reached their goal early exit polls put
Alexis tsipras and his serezha party
firmly in the lead it looks like Alexis
tsipras new brand of Greek politics has
paid off he's got the common touch with
his open collar and winning smile he's
promised to confront the European Union
over austerity he also says he'll
arrange for a haircut on Greek debt as
voting started he was confident this
will be an historic day the Greek people
will take this step and we'll get our
dignity back edited Cyprus has struck a
nerve with many Greeks he's spoken of
boosting pensions and increasing the
minimum wage that resonates here after
years of skyrocketing unemployment and
cuts and benefits Sita set captain I
voted for someone that I believe will
help this country that's who I believe
will do something for us the middle
class get the usual TF people i think
the middle class has been hurt the most
by thing last week the nogales amia in
Amos a taxi mister but I think things
will change now I believe this situation
will get better I'm tired of going
through the same things with the same
politicians many greats were still
undecided even as they went to the polls
some are worried about taking on the
powerful players in the EU and there's a
great deal of unease about a possible
exit from the eurozone
incumbent Prime Minister Antonis Samaras
tried to play on those fears your
glorious of Disney cathode is to kiss
these elections are decisive our future
and the future of our children then
today we decide if we go forward with
strength security and confidence that's
falija or if we start out on an unproven
adventure some pumice have been a bit
this so far it looks as if voters are up
for an adventure but it still seems
unlikely that serezha will win a big
enough majority to govern alone they'll
likely have to do the difficult work of
coalition building and that means
compromising on campaign promises